the world champion u.s. women's soccer
team will return to the World Cup final
if it can beat England today both teams
have won all their games so far Roxana
Saberi is at the stadium in Lyon France
Roxana what are the players saying ahead
of this game well the teams have been
praising each other but England's coach
has accused the US team of bad manners
and both teams are boasting that they
can win the game here later today as
three-time World Cup champions
confidence comes naturally to Team USA
but since beating France the fourth
ranked team in the world last week
they're getting it with accusations that
they're more than self-assured they're
arrogant I don't think our team is
arrogant at all I think that our team is
confident um we're respectful of our
opponents their next opponent England
also believes it can take home the
trophy this will be only the second time
that Team USA takes on England in a
World Cup the last time the u.s. won 3
to 0 but that was 12 years ago now the
teams are more evenly matched England
has reached new heights with new coach
Phil Neville he's praised his opponents
ruthlessness it's the gold medal that
everybody wants and I've got to say
America have got that ruthless streak of
wanting to win but he's questioning
their etiquette in an incident now dub
Spygate by British press Team USA staff
were spotted checking out his team's
hotel in Lyon reportedly as a possible
place to stay the u.s. beats England and
goes on to the final not something that
we do send some around to another
another teams hotel but it's their
problem us coach Jill Ellis brushed off
the allegation that it's another example
of her team's arrogance that's got
nothing to do with us that's planning
and preparation for our staff
to be clear FIFA dictates where teams
will stay so if the u.s. defeats England
here later today it will be required to
move into that hotel whoever wins will
compete in the final here on Sunday
against either the Netherlands or Sweden
Anthony Roxana Saberi at the Women's
World Cup thanks Forex Anna I do I don't
know when arrogance or confidence
becomes arrogance they're very close to
each other I think and when checking out
a hotel becomes spying
oh no I hate that we're getting dubbed
as arrogant though their fathers I don't
like it either but confident but
confidence is a good this is a team that
well everybody wants to win the British
coach envied what did he call it they're
ruthless